so the state of texas announced that
they're going to start bussing illegal
immigrants
more than a million have come through
texas in the last year to washington dc
and we criticized that i mean it's a
pretty funny idea but the
real question is how do you keep people
who have no right to be here out of the
country in the first place and actually
to be fair the governor of texas greg
abbott may have come up with a plan to
do that so the governor of the nuevo
leon province in mexico has just
announced he promises to curb illegal
migration north he's doing this in
response to something greg abbott did
abbott impose strict safety checks on
trucks coming from several provinces in
mexico
so this is a huge economic problem for
mexico abbott said he'd lift the new
requirements if the mexican government
of these provinces agreed to do
something about the migrants and one
province has now agreed we hope that
others soon follow we want to hear more
about this from the governor of texas
greg abbott who joins us tonight
governor thanks for coming on
my pleasure tucker so what we have done
is uh we implemented what we call
enhanced safety inspections of every
commercial vehicle coming across the
border
of every border
crossing from mexico into the state of
texas uh and it had the predictable
result and that is uh is stalled traffic
for miles in new mexico uh basically
crashing uh economic conditions in these
states as well as in the country of
mexico and having severe economic
consequences for businesses in mexico
and the predictable result
is that these governors of
states that are connected to the state
of texas would be knocking on a door
begging for relief and as they beg for
relief we are demanding uh that they
implement security measures that will
reduce illegal immigration coming across
their border there are different
standards that we will be applying to
different states that are connected to
the state of texas yesterday we
announced an agreement with the governor
of nuevo leon
today we are hammering out details with
two more states that are adjacent to
texas they have border crossings in
texas that will have some different
measures different measures that enhance
security that stops the flow of illegal
immigrants from their states of the
state of texas and then there will be
one more state governor that we are
dealing with tomorrow to try to hammer
out details with them all together
we expect that we demand that on the
mexican side they finally step up and
and stop these low water crossings and
other actions that are allowing these
illegal immigrants to cross the border
if they fail to do that we are going to
continue with our right to inspect every
single vehicle coming across that bridge
into the state of texas regardless of
the economic consequences it poses to
mexico
so i mean this suggests that politicians
in mexico have been abetting this mass
migration into the united states it's
about to get worse as you know next
month when the biden administration
lifts any kind of covert restrictions on
immigration we're expecting a huge wave
into your state do you think this is
enough to to stop
it listen this is a meaningful step to
reduce it uh it there there are other
measures that the state of texas has
taken uh to to make sure that we are
addressing this as fully as we can we
are the only state in the history of
america uh to build a border wall we're
laying down miles or razor where we're
putting bloat
boat blockades on the river to prevent
people from coming across uh we are
turning back people who are trying
either trying to cross the border or do
cross the border turning them back those
who make it through we are arresting and
putting in jail so we are using multiple
strategies to reduce the migration into
the state of texas tucker one
consequence of this you may see
heightened migration attempts in other
states like new mexico and california
where there being less resistance as
texas is but our job is to make it as
difficult as possible for the cartels to
get people to move people across the
border and state of texas our goal is to
put the cartels out of business make
them lose money trying to smuggle people
into the state of texas yeah
i mean
texas is all you can control you're only
the governor of one state um and this
seems this seems promising governor
gabit i appreciate coming on tonight
thank you
thank you tucker
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight